from Molly all week I've been subjected
to posts and personal messages that
educating my children about racism and
their white privilege not because of any
action I've taken it seems completely
inspired by the assumed the inevitable
racist beliefs me or my children will
fall into since I'm white as are my
children my question is how is that
different than me sending out messages
to liberal or african-american friends
saying may I suggest a few books that
help teach your kid how not to break a
store window and steal Gucci bags thanks
that is a very good comparison because
both of those things are equally
offensive right if you sent to your lip
to your leftist friends and your black
friends by virtue of their ideology and
their skin color note that said hey
here's a way to educate yourself and how
not to steal Nikes that would be very
offensive they would be rightly offended
by that likewise if they're if they're
sending you books and saying hey look I
know we're friends and everything but
because of your skin color you're evil
so here's a book on how not to be evil
like me because I'm a good person and
you're an evil person so here's here's
how not to be evil say okay thanks
that's great just throw in the trash if
this is a minute eyes in a little bit
with a religious answer white privilege
is a stand-in for original sin it's a
stand-in for our natural religious
understanding that we're broken that
we're falling something's not right
there's injustice in the world the
trouble with white privilege though is
it allows people it allows some people
to feel the goodness of like whipping
yourself and feel the goodness of
atoning for your sins and it allows
other people just to hate you just to be
like yeah you're the problem not me I
have no problems so it actually is kind
of exacerbates the worst parts of both
of this because it makes some people
aware of their imperfection but with
nothing to do about it and it makes it
actually leaves other people ignorant of
their own imperfections and breeds
hatred and division in the country it's
just a dumb idea it's a terrible idea
and we shouldn't give any quarter to it
you know
that there is a squishy response to this
whole BLM peaceful rioters kind of thing
which is you saw it from Jim mattis
actually the former defense secretary
you saw it from George W Bush a little
bit
which is to say hey look these guys they
have a point BLM has a point the rioters
they have a point you know it's real
they're expressing pain and the way they
express pain is by stealing Nikes and
Gucci bags no they don't have a point
they don't it's a lie it is based on a
lie we went through the numbers
yesterday went through them a little bit
again today it is not true they have no
point whatsoever the things that they're
doing based on their lie are terrible
they're indefensible their sins they are
crimes the people who are committing
those crimes should be arrested and
thrown in prison for a very long time
some people insist that we have to
pretend like they have a point in the
spirit of national unity wrong sorry
Buster actually if you pretend they have
a point you are you were achieving
precisely the opposite of national unity
you are encouraging discord you are
couraging strife you're encouraging
violence for nothing for a lie for a
ranked lie don't do it much much better
to take a clean and truthful approach
[Music]
you